i really like your documentary for so
many reasons i think this whole doc
while it follows you on tour
it's interesting to see how really
involved you are
emotionally and physically with this
show
and how concerned you are that fans will
actually enjoy it
how often does worry creep in when
you're creating a show like this
and at what point do you go and just put
it to the side and you're like nope
we're doing it we're going for it
oh both all the time i'm a worrier
anyway i wake up worrying
i worry enough for all of us but
yeah i just i want i guess from my
theater background and i love every
different kind of music
i want the experience to be emotional
and i want it to be every
kind of emotion that you can pack into
two hours as possible
you know i i want people to get angry i
want people to be excited i want people
to be
afraid i want people to be so connected
to their pain and emotions and joy
it's just that's that's my whole point
of putting a show together
and then once you do all that you got to
put all that to the side and just go for
it and
light this on fire light this on fire i
like it you say that
another line in the the dock you said
that you're not intimidated by
other people's success was that always
your vibe or is that something you had
to work on
going through the industry i'm super
competitive so i probably have had to
work on it but
the thing about music the thing about
the whole
this whole world is that everybody can
win
yeah everybody can win at the same time
and so
i don't know i just i don't know i feel
very lucky i feel i
my gratefuls are my list is long when i
watch the documentary and i watch your
acrobatics on stage
it's become your signature you're
inspired by cher did you ever have you
ever had an
opportunity to tell cher that she
inspired this
what did she say yes she's she's a
total nut case i love her so
hard she's just nuts she's so smart
she's so witty
she's such a badass she's been doing
this for a very
long time and she hasn't lost her sense
of humor
so i love that one of my shiros oh
it surprised me to learn though that you
have asthma and that you find you
sing better when you're upside down than
standing still
really yeah and scientifically i believe
it's uh something about screaming upside
down maybe it takes pressure off your
diaphragm
i'm not sure but it works okay that's
how much time do you need to recover
from a show because
i've never seen a performer like that i
mean whether it's the acrobatics the
amount of running that you do
um how long does it take you recover and
what do you do to recover
in between in between shows it's about
just one night's sleep
and then after a full tour of like 200
shows then it's like i don't know
two weeks to just crawl into a corner
and rock
and then i'm ready to go again maybe a
couple bottles of wine
also some sourdough yes
i'm good to go that's perfect you
you expose um on the documentary so much
about your touring life
and everything seems so incredible and
then you see the 24
bags that you travel with would carry
say that you're a mild order would we oh
absolutely he wanted me to be on
celebrity hoarders
i went to my dad's house recently and i
found all these empty uh
cases that no one would need like i
think there was like an empty flonase
cartridge so i know where it comes from
and there's nothing wrong with that
because what if you need something that
you thought you didn't need 10 years ago
and now you need it
again i want to be supportive
i do but i i i think we need to talk
about that
i've had this sweater for
17 years okay but that makes sense
flonase i don't know
well i'm not keeping the flonase that's
jim okay okay
okay that's good and i didn't know you
were a knitter outside of all this
rocker and then a knitter would you knit
some of your own clothes
no i'm not that good beanies beanies and
baby blankets
i like that i took two years knitting
willow a
big huge purple mohair
blanket because it was her favorite
color by the time i was finished
it wasn't her favorite color anymore and
i'm not even sure where it is but i know
it's in the house
somewhere because you're gonna keep it
forever right you're gonna keep it
forever i get it i might again
i see the theme here i get it when i was
watching this prod uh your project your
documentary it really felt to me like a
love letter
to your family as a mom of two kids
myself
it resonated with me because you talk
about going back to work after starting
a family and that
it's that crazy guilt that you feel and
the pressure you put on yourself to keep
living that normal life that's a lot of
weight to carry how do you cope with all
of that
i'm not sure that i do okay
i have a really twisted sense of humor
and i
i read a lot of really interesting books
i have friends
like the other day uh i said something
like
wildly inappropriate to willow out of
anger and i called my friend
crying and my friend goes oh that's
nothing guess what i just told my kid
and i was like see this is why
we need friends
[Laughter]
it's true though i think we just have to
have a sense of humor and we have to
give ourselves or at least if we can't
do it for ourselves do it for others
give
others a break our kids are
safe they're healthy we're doing the
absolute best that we can
it is what it is i mean it's a weird
world i feel like i always said i'm not
gonna age out of things i'm not gonna be
a dinosaur
i'm gonna know what what you know
apps kids social media i'm gonna know
what drugs kids are doing
i'm gonna know i am so i'm
so gone already now if my phone breaks
i'm like here willow you're nine
fix it so i don't know i don't know what
i'm doing
like i'm over here knitting i'll just
take that
so you know you it looks like how you
wind down is meditation
um a really a cool mat that looked
pretty amazing and
wine are those the three pillars to
to bring you back to center and cheese
let's not forget cheese
okay cheese is a very important part of
my life
okay i get it there's a line in the dock
where you say
most women stop touring this guy i found
this kind of heartbreaking but i
i understand it that most women stop
touring when they have kids was there
ever a moment for you where it kind of
crushed your mind like
okay i i can't i can't tour and do this
and do the family thing
absolutely i it crosses my mind all the
time
and one interesting thing that i've read
about this last year is
women have been the ones that have had
to stay home while their kids are home
we've been the ones still in 2021 that
have to give up our
our passions and our our livelihoods to
stay home with the children so yeah
that's the question i'm constantly
asking it's like
can a woman have it all what is all what
does that mean
what are the compromises what are your
priorities and
ultimately what is going to bring you
the most joy and so it's just this
constant
inner dialogue of trying to constantly
reimagine
what what am i doing what is this okay
is this okay and i think we have to ask
ourselves that question
a lot more than anybody else
absolutely today i pulled my kids off of
school because i was like i can't do it
like i can't do the tutoring and the
thing that they can't do it and so
something has to give i think
in the balance of it all some days i
look at it like
we're all doing the best that we can
we're all trying to put one foot in
front of the other
and our kids also as women they have the
right
and the need to see us filled up to
they have the right to see us fill our
cup
and have girlfriends and take time for
ourselves
and follow our passions it is inspiring
for them to see us fill our own cup
and then when they get grown up when
they grow up they'll say
oh i have the right to fill my own cup
no matter what any of you say because my
mom did it and she taught me how
that's right no that's a great message
that's an okay that's an okay lesson for
me yeah
i love how you prioritize to the family
when you're on tour you're like i want
to make sure the tour family is okay
but i want to create memories talk a
little bit about how important it is
and how much of a focus it is for you to
create those memories for your family
on the road oh it's everything
and it's it's sort of i look at tor like
a photo album
it's really really hard it's really it's
damn near impossible
sometimes but what you remember is
those snapshots those magical moments
those memories
yeah um i think life is that it's just
getting you know jumping over the lava
to get to the next magical memory so
yeah it's there's so many opportunities
especially with a crew like mine my
whole crew is so magical
and they love life and life has not been
easy
for for them um it's not like we're all
just like these drunk people running
around the world
with our heads in the sand no we
struggled to get where we are and now
we're
breathing easy because we're around each
other yeah
you can see that i like that you said no
matter what age you are if you're good
at what you do you stay
because you're aging too i thought that
was a really powerful message
too in this day and age of things being
disposable
people being disposable it seems yeah
yeah i mean look at tina turner and cher
and sade and
paul mccartney yeah there's no reason
to stop unless you want to
and it's a great message i've had you
know back my
background singers have said like you
know
we were worried that we were going to be
too old for this and i'm like
you sound great as long as you want to
be here you're here
yeah it's amazing